[Musique]
ambiance discothèque au centre social de
la mosaïque de plaisir c'est en effet
ici que sakho mamadou connu sous le
pseudonyme dit james donne des cours de
deejing avec son association la school
dit james
une idée qui lui est venue juste après
sa formation
j'ai fait une formation qui m'a permis
d'acquérir toutes les compétences que
j'ai aujourd'hui
c'est une formation de didier
producteurs formation dj producteur à
l'école qu'est school dans
13e et après moi par la suite j'ai j'ai
donné quelques cours à des enfants qui
souhaitaient
souhaitez apprendre amitié c'est là que
c'est là que ça m'a pris de dire
pourquoi pas monter une école en
assurant modeste natif pour pour faire
avec plusieurs enfants comment
aujourd'hui une dizaine d'adolescents de
10 à 18 ans viennent assister aux cours
de 10 james un atelier musical soutenue
par le conseil départemental et la
mairie de plaisir que les enfants
adorent la musique déjà c'est une
passion j'adore ça parce que c'est le
fait de maître de musique en même temps
trouver le mode et ou de mélanger
d'ambiance et des personnes etc
je trouve sakho ligue 1 j'ai appris à
manier les musiques et les mélanges et
en même temps à la rentrée prochaine le
projet de sako mamadou sera de
transformer cette activité en cours
récurrents but c'est d'abord un lieu
fixe sur la commune de plaisir pouvoir
accueillir que tous les jeunes les
jeunes qui veulent apprendre à miss et
après on va dire y'a pas approfondi que
le dj il ya le mix âprement dit avec
tous tes de matériel dj et après il ya
diverses métiers qui se profile à côté
c'est la musique assistée par ordinateur
compositeur voilà compositeur il ya le
vix qui elle avait une vidéo mix il ya
du scratch
et énormément de dessous le métier à
côté du monde du 10 gay qui peut
épanouir pas mal de monde pour
s'inscrire gratuitement ou pour plus
d'informations rendez vous directement
sur le site de la school dit james
la prochaine séance se déroulera le 19
août de 14h à 18h à la mosaïque de
plaisir